depuis la nuit des temps qu'est ce tu
fais roman là je mange une banane avec
tes pieds
[Musique]
sans doute entendu dire que l'homme
descend du singe
bah c'est faux oui c'est faux parce que
on a des origines communes avec eux mais
en réalité les singes c'est pas nos
ancêtres c'est nos frères nos soeurs nos
cousins nos cousines et on est juste des
primates comme eux ont fait partie de
leur famille celle des hominidés
bon allez si vous refusez me croire
voilà cinq preuve qu'on est des animaux
la meilleure preuve qu'on est des
animaux on a une que une toute petite
mais on a eu un petit parfum dans
l'utérus de nos mamans on a tous et
toutes une que quand on est à l'état
d'embryon mais elle disparaît quand on
vient des foetus sauf des fois la
naissance on a encore un reste de ce qui
a été notre que lé là tout en bas de
notre dos et on la voit pas de
l'extérieur normalement alors on va
aller faire un petit tour à l'intérieur
notre colonne vertébrale comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est un empilement vertèbres
elle commence sous notre crâne avec les
cervicales elle se prolonge par les
dorsales et elle se termine par les
lombaires puis le sacrum qui est le
résultat de la soudure entre elles de
cinq vertèbres qu'on appelle les
vertèbres sacré et pour finir il ya le
coccyx qui vient s'articuler sur le
sacrum le coccyx et un petit bout d'os
qui est lui aussi formé de quatre ou
cinq vertèbres soudées entre elles qui
est un petit peu en forme de bec
d'oiseau et qui tient son nom de cox us
le coucou coucou tu veux voir mais qu'on
appelle une structure vestiges yal cette
attaque c'est un vestige de ce qui a été
notre cas mais comme aujourd'hui on n'a
plus besoin d'une que pour assurer notre
équilibre et qu'on a trouvé d'autres
moyens pour chasser les mouches elle a
disparu et il nous reste plus que ce
petit souvenir mais c'est pas tout
et bakou parce qu'un vestige de notre
animalité on en a aussi un qui se voit
comme le nez au milieu de la figure
sauf qu'il est caché et qui n'est pas
sur notre nez mais dans nos yeux
jeux jeux sont joués perdure si vous
regarder d'un peu plus près juste là au
coin de votre oeil
bon vous allez toucher mais si vous
regarder d'un peu plus près juste là au
point de cet oeil vous allez remarquer
une petite membrane c'est l'application
millénariste un pli de la conjonctive
qui est un vestige de la membrane nick
qui tentent aussi appelé troisième
paupières j'ai un certain nombre
d'animaux elle recouvre l'oeil
horizontalement pour le protéger ou le
nettoyer sans masquer la vue puisqu'elle
n'est pas au pack chez les humains il en
reste un petit bout mais vraiment pas
grand chose de bon en même temps depuis
là encore on a trouvé d'autres moyens de
se protéger les yeux en y voyant clair
quand même alors me qui tente la
membrane mais c'est pas tout au rayon
des structures vestiges l on peut aussi
citer les troisième molaire houdan
sagesse elles sont là tout au fond de
votre bouche et si on voulait retire
c'est pas seulement parce qu'ils ont la
fâcheuse habitude de peigner les
lendemains de soirées trop arrosées
d'ailleurs on les retire plus
systématiquement mais seulement quand
elle pose problème et si elles sont les
dernières à pousser en réalité ça fait
très longtemps qu'elle existe parce
qu'en des temps ancestraux elle servait
à mastiquer longuement et à broyer des
aliments fibre ou dur comme de la viande
crue ou des végétaux
autant vous dire qu'aujourd'hui chez la
plupart des gens elle sert plus à grand
chose à tel point qu'il semblerait qu'il
ya de plus en plus d'enfants chez qui
elle construit et pour finir avec les
structures vesti vial on peut aussi
citer les amygdales dans le fond de
votre gorge et l'appendice dans le fond
de votre côlon fait remarquer c'est que
des trucs que les chirurgiens on nous
enlève sans que ça vous manque vraiment
mais c'est pas tout
y a pas que des organes qu'on a gardé du
temps on était des bêtes il ya des
réflexes aussi comme la chair de poule
par exemple ou plutôt comme la pilot
érection ou horripile à sion chez les
animaux à forte pilosité les muscles et
recteur du poil ou au révélateur ont
pour fonction de dresser les poils sur
la peau ça 2 grande utilité quand il
fait froid d'abord ça permet au pelage
d'emprisonner contre la peau une plus
grande quantité d'air qui sert d'isolant
thermique et en cas de grosse frayeur
c'est à dire principalement en cas d'
attaque d'un prédateur gonfler sa
fourrure ça rend l'animal plus
impressionnant en augmentant son volume
est bien l'humain a gardé ses muscles et
recteur du poil et le réflexe qui va
avec
bon on est d'accord que dans les deux
cas ça nous sert assez peu au quotidien
mais on a gardé le cadeau vous le mètre
carré
mais c'est pas tout
il ya quand même une différence entre
nous et les autres animaux un poney par
exemple ils ces marchés quasiment dès sa
naissance alors que nous alors que nous
aussi figurez-vous grâce aux réflexes
archaïques de la marche automatique un
nouveau nez humain est capable de
marcher si on tient sous les aisselles
il est même capable d'enjamber des
obstacles attention c'est pas quelque
chose que le bébé maîtrise ça s'explique
par le fait qu'à la naissance le système
nerveux n'est pas complètement mature et
fonctionne essentiellement par réflexe
comme celui ci où le fait de tester ce
qu'on lui met dans la bouche
vers trois ou quatre mois la partie du
système nerveux responsables des
mouvements volontaires et mature et le
réflexe de marche automatique
disparaître il faut alors que le bébé
réapprennent à marcher selon un schéma
qui d'après une étude italienne utilise
exactement la même chaîne de commande
nerveuse que celle des bébés rats dans
la même situation
vous voyez bien qu'on ait des bestioles
et devinez quoi cette fois c'est tout
dtc c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle vidéo continue à me poser vos
questions je note tout c'est promis
abonnez vous pour être sûr de rien
louper en attendant garder la pêche
et surtout surtout pour toulouse
[Musique]
oui